this is to put we call it to food
because it is food that is packed in a
tube you tube pilots in the Air Force
are a lot like astronauts
they fly as high as 72 thousand feet and
there's no oxygen so they wear
pressurized suits and helmets to breathe
the only way to eat is to slurp through
a straw what we do here is we make and
design rations for the US military we
are the only people in the world who
make it and these are two fools
we have approximately 19 different
varieties that we make here apple pie
Key Lime Pie beef stew truffle mac and
cheese the products used to be very
grade it looked a lot like baby food in
fact many of the pilots used to think
that Gerber manufactured the tube fruits
for them but about five years ago the
pilots came up to us and they wanted
something that had texture more like
regular food if you have a beef stew
they want that to be able to taste the
peas and the carrots and the meat in the
potato separately not just as one mashed
up product so Dan and his team of food
scientists in this lab set to work we
try to grind things up so they do have a
particle size that's small enough to fit
through this tube yet still gives the
texture that the person would normally
have those tube food flavors aren't the
only thing they've developed in this lab
from powdered cheese to instant coffee
they've invented a number of products
that eventually made their way into
civilian life
so is tube food our future there hasn't
been an effective use of these products
in this country outside of the you tube
but we can see where it might be useful
for like students in a dormitory campers
anyone who wants to have an easy eat on
the go item